you know we could all use a little bit
of encouragement now and then again
right well now some of you can get it 24
7 on a brand new hotline listen to this
this might be my favorite story npr
reports pep talk is a hotline that
delivers pep talks from kindergarteners
two yeah i know two teachers name
jessica martin and ashira weiss put
together this art project at westside
elementary school in hillsboro
california and here when you dial a
number this is the audio you get listen
please listen to the following options
for encouraging messages
if you're feeling mad frustrated or
nervous press one
if you need it words of encouragement
and life advice press two
if you need a pep talk from
kindergarteners press three i know i
know i know you would love this
i know
before the show i read this story so i
called and i actually i i pushed three
for a pep talk and it was like a group
of what i think was like 30
kindergartners and they all said in
unison you can do it
and i believe them i do believe them i
can do it
but the teachers say you guys this this
hotline is so popular they've gotten up
to 900 calls a minute oh my gosh
and you can keep it going you go to our
website to find out how you can support
their hotline costs but you can call
this number i think it's so brilliant
because it shows the kids like an
unconventional way to make a difference
in this world and that they are
important
you know what i mean that they can like
change grown-ups
well here's another something that i
really love we love to find little bits
of joy to brighten our day
and it turns out every single day there
is something to celebrate because
every day is a holiday
[Applause]
it's true it's always national french
fry day or best friend's day or love
your dog day well guess what this
saturday was national girl scout day but
we're keeping the celebration going
please welcome the daisy troop from
rivervale new jersey isabella riley
ashlynn and riley
hi
hi hi hi this is
[Applause]
oh hello girls hello
hi how are you now will you please state
your name
isabella isabella kylie hawkes riley
hawkes
ashland
ashlynn
riley noonan
riley that's so nice to meet you
interesting that both of you riley's
have flowers in your hair
is that a quince is that an accident or
on purpose
action we just put any flowers in my
hair because it it fought it would look
nice
well
it does and it does it does
and you put a heart in your hair
do you like hearts yeah i do too
and i love your pink bow thank you i
think it looks so pretty
which is your favorite girl scout cookie
dead mints i do a thin mint oh well
i cannot thank you guys enough for
coming here now i'd like to ask you one
more question too what's your favorite
part of being a girl scout um i like to
sell cookies
and what's your favorite part of being a
girl scout
being nice
being nice
oh riley ashlynn what's your favorite
being nice
nice
and
i can't
i'm so cute
you guys are this cute and you brought
us cookies okay you win the day you win
the day i have to say
well
thank you so much for bringing us these
delicious cookies and all the hard work
that you daisies do for your communities
and ross and i have a little something
for you that's right we wanted to award
you these drew's news badges for taking
a field trip to come and see us
there's one for you
you were wondering if we could get these
patches put on your special clothes
and also we're gonna buy a whole bunch
of your cookies and make your sales go
through the roof
how does that sound
[Applause]
good for business
all right and we're also going to put
you guys and your troop on our website
so that people can buy your cookies or
figure out how to support and donate to
uh you know contribute to the daisy
troupe
well thank you isabella riley ashland
riley thank you so much for coming here
you're beautiful
okay i i this was my favorite may i have
a thin mint should we all have a cookie
yeah yes which kind i'm gonna have this
one wait what did you say you're really
beautiful i am
that's so funny because i think the very
same thing about you
you're so beautiful do you know where
it's the most important place to be
beautiful
here
and home
yes
and inside
yes in your heart exactly you all have
beautiful hearts
and this was my favorite drew's news
we've ever gotten to do because of you
guys
[Music]
you